hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about
bts the korean k-pop group
and how well they speak chinese and
[Music]
english
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell to get notifications
and by all means join me at link which
is where i learn languages
so a friend said to me do you know the
korean
k-pop group bts and i said no never
heard of them
so let's begin by giving you a brief uh
you know
excerpt from one of their songs
[Music]
which you can find all over the the uh
you know youtube internet
they're apparently the number one
selling uh pop music group in the world
it's just that
me being an old folky i'd never heard of
them um
but so the friend said can you sort of
critique their chinese in english so i
looked at this
interview where they're speaking in
chinese and in english
foreign
wow handsome
every time every moment you know my
first reaction is that that
these guys are just great you know i've
listened to some of their songs their
music
obviously is great their dance routines
are great i mean they're very
professional they're very good at what
they do
but their message is so positive and
their message is one of
inclusiveness we're living in a world
that is it's global increasingly global
whatever we may think about that we may
regret the fact that we're
more global but we're going to be
increasingly global there's more and
more mutual
influence affecting food and music i
mean even this k-pop
group i mean their music reflects
influences from
from uh however any however many
continents from africa
from latin america from north america
from
asia uh and and so they are
international so uh and
and um so now getting to the subject
of of their use of language they of
course
haven't gone at the study of chinese or
english in terms of
accumulating lots of words you know my
focus at link always is to acquire
many many words so that i can read so
that i can understand
movies uh theirs is a more
a lighthearted touch at these languages
but the
by the same token their music is an
opportunity to learn korean
or even other languages uh i looked at
one of their videos on youtube
and uh they offer subtitles in a variety
of languages
i for whatever reason maybe youtube knew
that i'm learning arabic
the subtitles were there in arabic so i
imported that into link so now i can
go through their lyrics which are of
course originally in
in korean and english and i can go
through them in arabic
eric of our of link he has on his blog
on the link blog gone into some detail
on how to
import uh you know these korean songs
with the lyrics
into link and then learn korean from
their music
so these are the ways in which we can
you know connect
with um you know bts
but their use of the languages that they
spoke in this interview
and again i'll have a link to that
discussion is quite different in
approach
theirs is an expression of joy of
happiness
in using languages and so they imitate a
chinese person
or an english-speaking person and they
do so
very well they pull it off it's it's
meant
it's not meant to to to make fun of say
chinese speakers
but to me as a non-native speaker of
chinese
i thought they did it very well the sort
of intonation the
the gestures and stuff
they captured that sort of essence by
only speaking a very few words
the pronunciation was good and as i say
they were using real words
um sometimes people might imitate an
italian or a frenchman or a chinese
person and just use
non-words nonsensical words or sometimes
you'll hear
people going you know imitating chinese
ching chong changing which is just silly
whereas there they were using a small
number of words to sort of
uh participate in a in a positive way
in chinese culture and then they did the
same with english so a lot of you know
how's it going type of
you know casual now obviously as a
native speaker of english
i can hear their accent i can hear where
the words they
they use were not quite correct it
doesn't matter
it's done in a lighthearted way and
therefore they pulled it off
and i think that they represent
something that's very positive
the message of inclusiveness that we're
all connected
just the fact that they offer their
videos with subtitles in so many
different languages
and obviously the music is is very
popular
i don't have all the statistics at hand
but i gather they want an award
there they have fans all over the world
their videos
are you know millions and millions of
people viewing them
so um i just am glad
that someone asked me to um you know
listen to their use of chinese in
english
because you know i then became aware of
this phenomenon that i had not been
aware of
and uh you know it's it's sort of in
line
i'm an older generation i have a uh
call it a more serious approach to to
language learning i struggle i work hard
to
acquire more and more words uh but these
people are just enjoying they've
obviously had fun being with chinese
people being with american people
with japanese people they spoke some
japanese they spoke some thai
and they just enjoy that sense of
of of being together with people of
different cultures
where to some extent we mix these
cultural influences and at the same time
we maintain
what is valuable to us in our own
culture so
everything about them having discovered
them through this
you know request from a friend to
critique their
uh their use of chinese and english has
has introduced me to this phenomenon
which i think is extremely positive
by the way my videos are also available
on podcasts
so for those of you who are learning
english and don't want to spend the time
watching a video
you should look into getting the
podcasts uh
where you know transcripts are also
available
uh and i think they're on spotify and
itunes and so forth and so on so that's
just a bit of a hint for those who
who use these to learn or to improve
their english because anything that you
can find that's interesting
is going to help you in your language
learning same with me with korean
i have to admit that i've struggled with
korean i've done korean off and on at
different times for six months here six
months there i never really achieved the
level that i would like to achieve
part of it is that when i started we
didn't have the many stories for korean
at link which we now do
and second of all we weren't able to
import material like
the the bts songs interlink
um now it's a lot easier to do that i
can even
import you know podcasts that i can
automatically transcribe
so if i were to go back to korean i
would do better
but my korean being as it is
uh whatever i've been able to do in it i
enjoy and
i'm going to end up here with two videos
that i would
you know suggest you might want to have
a look at one is uh
eric on his uh blog post this is not my
son by the way i have a son named eric
but this is not eric
he does a a description of how to import
k-pop or specifically bts songs into
link in order to
improve your korean and the other one is
just for reference a conversation that i
had with hannah
who is korean uh four years ago and that
was the last time i
sort of had an online conversation in
korean and you'll see that
i do struggle but it's something that
i'll go back to
so thank you for listening